-Welcome, welcome, welcome to
"The Tonight Show,"
ladies and gentlemen.
[ Cheers and applause ]
I'd like to start by wishing
everyone a happy New Year.
[ Cheers and applause ]
♪♪
Happy New Year.
Raise your hand
if you've already given up
on your New Year's resolutions.
Yeah, okay, good, yeah.
It's only been three days.
Isn't that sad? Yeah.
I think we should make
resolutions more realistic.
You know,
then we could always do them.
Like, how about we join a gym
and never go?
We can do that. I can do that.
How about keeping a journal from
January 1st to January 10th?
We can do that.
Alright, January 3rd.
January 3rd to January 5th.
Okay, we can do it.
How about this one?
How about just flossing once?
We can all do that.
These are resolutions...
But I love making
New Year's resolutions.
It's just like trying to give up
something for Lent,
but instead of
disappointing God,
it's only yourself, you know?
Of course, asking people about
their New Year's resolutions
is always strange.
It's like, "So, tell me, what do
you think is wrong with you?"
I read that, this year,
the most popular resolutions are
exercising, eating better,
and losing weight.
Yeah. You know we don't
keep our resolutions,
'cause last year,
they were the exact same things.
And get this -- a new survey
found that only 1 in 3 Americans
had a great 2022.
It's a pretty
interesting survey.
Check this out. 30% said...
30% said...
[ Cheers and applause ]
And you go, "That's..."
Who's your landlord?
-That's the worst!
-What?!
-I didn't know
he owned property.
-Speaking of, a lot of people
are talking about this.
Newly elected Congressman
George Santos,
is already facing calls to
resign because of a growing list
of scandals, including lies
he's told about his family,
education, and his work history.
Yep, it's odd when a congressman
holds up his right hand
to be sworn in, and everyone's
like, "You know what?
Don't bother."
When asked to address his lies,
Santos said,
"Listen,
I'm just focused on being
the best vice president
I can be."
Guys, real quick,
I want to say that we're so glad
that you're all here.
And right now, I want to take
a moment to welcome
a very special part of
our audience
that were all flown here thanks
to a special promotion from
Southwest Airlines.
Give it up for
the Southwest Fan Zone!
-♪ Celebrate good times,
come on ♪
-Wait a second.
Wait a second.
-They're actually
stuck in Akron.
I'm sorry.
Give it up for everyone in
the Southwest Fan Zone,
wherever they are.
[ Cheers and applause ]
Wherever you're watching from.
That's right -- last week,
Southwest left passengers
and luggage
across the country stranded
after they suffered
a major meltdown
and canceled more than
15,000 flights.
Southwest said that they
were launching an investigation
into the meltdown, but then they
immediately canceled it.
The cause of the cancelations
was mainly due to their
"outdated technology."
You never want to hear
your airline
as the same sentence as
"outdated technology."
You go...
Some entertainment news.
CNN held their annual
New Year's Eve special.
It was great.
Andy Cohen is our buddy.
Anderson Cooper.
They were not allowed
to drink this year.
They weren't allowed --
Well, let's see how that went.
-You know, in Iran, I don't know
if they still do it,
but for a while,
when they hang people,
it's not hanging somebody
and letting them drop
which breaks their neck,
instantly kills them.
It's picking somebody up
with a crane
so that it's actually
suffocation and strangulation.
-Yeah, no, it's pretty --
-It's particularly brutal.
-3, 2, 1...
-Happy new year!
-Wow! Wow!
-Wow! That was not drinking?
-That -- Wow!
The head of CNN was like,
"Somebody get Anderson
a Jagermeister -- stat!"
Wow!
Happy New Year, everybody.
-Yeah.
-Holy moly.
You see Andy's face?
That was -- Andy's like,
"Alright, alright."
Some movie news.
Less than three weeks
since its release,
"Avatar: The Way of Water"
has already topped $1.4 billion
at the global box office.
$1.4 billion.
Meanwhile,
the Blue Man Group was like,
"What are we doing wrong here?
What are we..."
Listen to this.
According to a new study,
drinking around 10 cups of water
can slow the aging process.
-Ooh!
-That's right.
Water can add years
to your life,
yet people are still going to be
like, "Oh, it's Dasani?
Never mind."
Guys, finally, it is Tuesday.
It is time for "WeTweet."
Here we go.
-♪ "WeTweet" ♪
♪ "WeTweet" ♪
-Welcome to "WeTweet."
This is where we, as a group,
decide something
that we should post on Twitter.
I'm going to show
you five different tweets,
and we're all going to vote on
whether you
like each one or not.
You all have voting clickers
at your seats.
You see them there?
You can vote for
all of them, by the way.
every single one of them.
-Really?
-Yeah, it's never been done.
-But you can.
-But -- Well, the whole audience
has never voted for all of them,
but we can do it tonight
if we feel like doing it.
Or you can vote for
none of them.
I just want you
to have a good time.
You're here.
You're at the
"The Tonight Show."
I want you to
have fun, enjoy, and relax.
Higgins, Roots,
you guys have clickers, too?
-Got it.
-Whatever tweet
gets the most likes,
we will tweet it out
live on the show
so that you can all like it
and "WeTweet" it.
Yeah, yeah.
It's a shared experience.
Alright,
are you guys ready for this?
The first tweet is...
Hey, there you go.
♪♪
Wow.
-Wow! Thank you, no.
-I didn't even vote yet, but
I don't even know if I have to.
-Might be the first zero.
-"Screw it, I'm going to get
my 2023 glasses prescription."
-Because you wouldn't do that.
-You wear 'em all --
You wear 'em forever.
-You wouldn't normally do that.
-Reading glasses,
whatever you like.
-Yeah, yeah. That's the joke.
-I can already tell, just by --
this is a very honest audience.
-I'm going to say --
I'm gonna say less than 70.
-I saw some people put
the clickers down at one point.
-I saw some people leave.
-They refuse to vote.
Do we have to even
check the results?
Alright, let's see the results.
The votes are in.
[ Drumroll ]
-Whoa!
34.
-Oh, my God. 147.
-Wow!
-Might be the worst one yet.
-Gosh! I'm writing that down.
-Here's the other thing --
they all don't
necessarily get better.
-Right.
-Okay, here we go.
This next one says...
♪♪
Wow.
You sit in -- You can move.
You can move.
You don't have to -- Everyone's
just kind of sitting there.
So, if you don't hear the
tree fall, did it happen?
-Yeah. How egotistical.
-Oh, move on. Yeah.
-Are you talking to the tree or
the person who didn't hear it?
-The person that didn't hear.
-Don't go out on a limb
on this one.
I just want to know --
are you talking about the tree?
[ Rimshot ]
Are you gonna leave?
-I'm stumped.
-Oh, yeah.
♪♪
Either way, those are all
getting bigger laughs
than what -- Let's see
the results on this one here.
[ Drumroll ]
-Whoa!
-Alright. Again, you don't have
to be that honest, okay?
This is more for
entertainment's sake.
-For fun. We're goofing off.
Happy New Year!
-"If it didn't fall,
I don't know, did it happen?"
-"Hey, man."
-"Yeah, we did have a party,
Larry, and you weren't there."
Alright, here we go.
This next one says...
"Really? You are?"
-"Really?"
-"Wow!"
-"You dress like that?
Wow!"
-"I can take my shoes off
in your place?"
-"This is what you care about?"
-Let's see the results
on this one.
It feels better.
[ Drumroll ]
-Whoa!
-There we go.
Thank you.
[ Cheers and applause ]
Now we're talking.
-Wow!
-Now we're cooking with gas.
Now we're talking.
-That's more than
the combined --
-I'm loving this right here.
Yeah, that one...
Check out this one here.
-Come on!
-I feel that one.
People are nodding their heads.
People are smiling.
Look at the difference.
-Yeah, come on.
-People are smiling
and having a good time.
That's what I'm talking about.
Alright, here we go.
What do you think?
-It's got to be big.
-You feeling good?
-Yes.
-Let's see the results.
Can you beat -- Let's see
the results on this one.
-Whoa!
-Oh, yeah, baby!
♪♪
[ Cheers and applause ]
Yeah! Come on!
-177.
-That was --
That's hard to beat.
That was great.
Alright, that's good.
So even if nothing happens,
that happened.
Yeah, okay, good.
I appreciate --
-Is this the last one?
-This is the last one here.
-Ooh!
-It says...
♪♪
I think --
Password's gonna win, I think.
-Yeah.
-I feel like
password's gonna win.
-Password. Password.
-People are yelling
"password" out.
-Not the game?
-They're feeling it.
No, no. They like that tweet.
It's password.
Alright. Ready?
What do you think?
Password?
-Well, it's gotta beat 177.
-Password or pickle jar, right?
-This is 130-something.
-You think 130-something?
-Yeah, I think
it's around there, 140.
Yep, I'm with Quest.
But 177 is gonna take it.
-I'm gonna bid --
I'm gonna bid 150.
-I'll take 177.
-Let's see the results.
Oh! Hey, not bad!
-Oh!
-You're right, everybody!
The winner was number four.
[ Dinging ]
That is the new password!
That's what I'm talking about!
I'm going to post this
during the commercial break.
If you see it on your feed,
give it a like,
give it a "WeTweet" right now,
and enjoy.